hey everybody welcome I'm gonna be
talking today about how to achieve zero
down time migrations using Google Cloud
or GCP along with fastly my name is Sean
leech I'm the chief product officer here
at fastly and I think it'd be a pretty
interesting conversation
so quick background fastly is an edge
cloud one of the well-known products
that has been built on top of this edge
cloud a CDN and so we have quite a few
customers that serve their content and
their application globally around the
world using our very massive Network
yeah that not only can they serve
content but they can actually build
pretty complex applications on top of
this as well and take advantage of that
scale and reach you know our customers
are kind of the who's who out there
folks like the New York Times
Airbnb Spotify Spotify as well as Jeff
so I'll talk today about three
strategies around you know kind of
availability and performance the first
one will be around migrating from your
data center or other cloud provider to
GCP and how do you can use fasten to do
that I'm also going to talk about you
know pretty a newer topic but a pretty
fun topic around microservice routing
and load balancing
you've probably heard things like
service meshes etc we talked a bit about
that then we talked about multi cloud
load balancing strategies like how do
you use the fastly global server load
balancer between cloud providers to give
you some advantages on the performance
side on the availability side and your
on the cost side as well so load
balancing is a interesting term the name
itself is quite descriptive but I think
sometimes folks mistake load balancing
with like failover like oh if this
server fails go to another server that's
a component of load balancing but the
main focus and use of load balancing is
around distributing your inbound traffic
across your computing resources so you
know if you have three servers and you
have all these customers trying to get
access to your application how do you
distribute load across those servers to
best take advantage of your
infrastructure and then if one of those
servers fails then all the rest of all
the traffic will be distributed across
the two servers and when that third
server comes back up it'll redistribute
that traffic across that third server
traditional GSLV and I've been in this
kind of space a really long time
always use DNS previously so if you had
multiple data centers multiple clouds
your DNS server on every single DNS
request would make a decision whether to
route the end-user to one or of your
other back-end infrastructure now the
problem is is that DNS queries only
happened once every so often right you
have this concept of a TTL or
time-to-live where a DNS request will
will go from the client an answer will
be given and then that answer will be
cached for anywhere from one minute to
you know a day and so if you have
failures or
you know your back ends we can over
become overloaded it's very difficult to
use DNS as that routing layer because it
doesn't respond quick enough another
problem with DNS is the DNS request
comes from a recursive server doesn't
actually come from the end-user
themselves and a lot of times if you're
using like Google's DNS or CloudFlare
DNS or one of these big kind of anycast
recursive DNS farms your queries your
lumped in with a whole bunch of other
people's queries and so not only do you
not be are you not able to kind of do
load balancing on a specific in juice
your level your you aren't able to use
properties of the end-user as opposed to
the in DNS server to make decisions and
I'll talk about that a second so fastest
GSLV is quite a bit different we're
what's called a layer seven load
balancer and what we do is just you when
you make an HTTP request to some
resource that's behind fastly load
balancer we can make a decision both on
every single request because every HTTP
request goes to us as opposed to DNS
which gets cached but we also see the
requests come in from the end client
itself so we allow our customers to make
really complex load balancing decisions
based on the properties of the end
client so that could be a cookie value
it could be a particular header it can
be at the Geo where the end user is
coming from what you know ISP they're
using as well as you can take advantage
of if the backend for example sets a
particular cookie like let's say you're
a bank and you log in and the cook the
banks that's a cookie that says this is
one of our high profile customers a
layer seven load balancer is able to use
that information to make load balancing
decisions maybe it'll send it to them
the bigger you know compute farm the
faster compute fire was as opposed to
the slower computer again I have no idea
if they would do that but that is a
possibility so
talk a bit about cloud kind of
microservice load balancing strategies
you really want it to be infrastructure
agnostic and then you want to have a
unified approach right if you're using
kind of multiple clouds and they're
usually different you know providers
it's nice to have a single source of all
of your build balancing decisions and
infrastructure so I'm going to cover
some of that in our demos today but the
one of the beauties and I'll talk a bit
about this as well around multi cloud is
is the ability to take advantage of the
strengths and avoid the weaknesses of
different cloud providers and so I'll
talk a little bit about how you can use
our our load balancer to take advantage
of that so some again I talked a bit
about our the functionality that we
provide but the key points are
content-aware right we can look at the
URL the end users going to the
properties of the end-user and we can
make decisions based on that whether
it's a micro service or just a normal
monolithic application infrastructure
agnostic design like we can kind of a
lot we allow you to have a single place
where you can configure your routing in
your load balancing rules you don't have
to have like different rules for
different cloud providers it doesn't
matter as long as the backend speech HUP
you can use it media control and
insights like a big part of load
balancing is understanding right away
the health of your backends how how the
load balancing is working in terms of
what level of load and sending to this
server versus that server with our
system we give you full and real-time
access to all of the logs on every
single hit to the load balancer which
allows you to build some really cool
analytics and observability backends
using you know your favorite
infrastructure or analytics provider and
then scalability you know we're a
massive you know many many many tens of
terabytes a second you know tons of
locations around the world we instantly
scale up so you don't have to worry
about some of the cold start problems
that you've gotten with other load
balancing solutions or having to buy a
bunch of hardware and support it like
you've done you know for the past many
years so let's let's look into use case
number one you're in a data center you
know as a lot of you have been in the
past
now you know as a lot of folks want to
do in the future you want to move the
GCP like we're huge fans of GCP we use
TCP for a lot of our control plane
technology and so we can definitely see
why you would want to do this so let's
talk a bit about this why would you do
it I think it's pretty straightforward
you want to move to that you want to use
move to Google Cloud take advantage of
all the the benefits of cloud right
scalability analytics control and so but
what you want to do is you move to the
cloud is you want to make it seamless to
your end-users right you don't want to
like redirect them to a different server
so that they see the browser redirect
that can have a lot of problems when it
comes to performance you want to make it
as seamless as possible to move all of
your traffic from a data center provider
to a cloud provider and that's where a
layer 7 load balancer really comes into
its own in that because you have a
single DNS name that everybody sees
let's just use dub dub dub not example
comm in the layers have a load balancer
you can send be having all your traffic
to go to your primary data center and
then over time whether it's you could do
it be via geo you can do it based on
customers that have opted in you can
send a percentage of your traffic to
your new cloud infrastructure and that
way your end users actually never see
whether they're going to a data center
or cloud all they see is dub-dub-dub
that example comm and behind the scenes
you're doing all the work to make it
really easy and straightforward to move
them over and then if there's a problem
and you want to move back to the data
center it's instant you go out to wait
for dns to propagate which again can
take like up to a day sometimes so it's
a really powerful way of doing it and
you know as a provider that's for
developers by developers of course we
let everything that you do be
programmable our entire UI it only uses
the API like we're we're an API first
company we allow you to use terraform as
well if that's the solution that you
like to use but what you can see here is
this is just a simple API call that
allows you to change the like to create
a pool that is one for GC
P and then one for your data center and
then once it's activated within a second
or two globally that change happened so
like you don't have to make a change and
then wait for it to propagate for half
an hour for that traffic to start moving
it's an instant change it because of how
quickly you can push config changes out
that was one of our earliest kind of
competitive differentiators was not only
could you invalidate content instantly
which allow people to put like real-time
inventory behind us or like rapidly
changing home pages we also allowed you
and push your config changes out within
a second globally that kind of changed
the game of what you could do with a CDN
or an edge cloud so this is where you
can create multiple load balancers based
on you know different IP addresses so
you can do local load balancing as well
or things like service mesh which I'll
talk about in a bit but it gives you the
kind of that full power you can have
different kind of data centers that you
read you know send your traffic between
but then you can actually have different
load balancing algorithms between
servers within those data centers which
is really powerful and then because you
know the original like fastly was
originally based on a highly modified
version of varnish which is you know one
of the most popular caching you know
pieces of open-source software out there
we use a language called ECL to do your
configuration and so you can see here
that you can do a random load balancer
just by setting the backend and you can
fully program this it's not like you
only can use the UI to make your
decisions you have full program
programmatic access to configuring the
load balancer the classic example of
some folks have used this there's a you
know probably the biggest radio provider
out there they had to quickly move out
of their data center and into the cloud
like their their data center provider
had basically said you've got like a
week so we using our load balancer
didn't have to buy any new gear or
anything they just used our SAS
flow-based load balancer they slowly
were able to migrate that radio traffic
from the data center into the cloud and
there was no visit visible artifact of
that to their end users Andrew had no
idea that they had moved it you've got a
lot faster all
sudden and vineos another big customer
of ours they use this to move from net
storage which is a storage provider over
their previous CDN to using GCS as their
storage so they got to take advantage of
all the amazingness of GCS which again
we're huge fans of TCS and then they
were able to then move that traffic off
of their own legacy system into GCS and
we they use a really cool feature of
ours as well where we would actually
check GCS first as part of the move and
if it wasn't there if it had been
migrated yet we'd go to the previous
storage system again all behind the
scenes unknown of the end user so let's
talk about use case to micro services
right it's kind of the new hotness
service mesh and micro services and now
I'm even hearing this thing called macro
services so the IT world was always
changing but it's always a lot of fun as
well let's talk about like a
service-oriented architecture or micro
services routing so you have it's
similar if you think about a phone
conceptual level it's very similar to
multi cloud or multi datacenter but
instead you have multi services and
again HTTP is kind of the language of
the web and so as long as everything
speaks HTTP it's really simple so what
you can do is you can break that big
monolithic up into smaller sub services
or micro services and then you can use
fastly to route based on the proper
service based on the URL path right so
we have a lot of customers who have like
slash images we'll go to the image
service which may be hosted in the same
data center or a different cloud
provider etc then you may have a
kubernetes service that's running like
your shopping cart application so we can
route anything that goes to slash cart
or slash product to that particular app
and then you might have you know a
third-party integration with some you
know graph QL API or something like that
so / yeah I can go to a different
service and again it's all done on every
single request at the layer 7 level and
if any of those fails we can instantly
failover to a backup provider
connect who's like you know one of the
biggest publishers out
there they own USA Today and a ton of
newspapers they use faceted rap to all
their back in micro-services so and the
other beauty of fastly because we're
100% both real-time and API control they
can integrate all of this into their
cncd workflow so they don't have to have
like all their testing and deployment
pipeline using the CI CD system and then
they're also they're load balancers or
CDN service everything is fully
programmable so every change that they
make the test is done based on their
cloud infrastructure and the
configuration on fastly in real time so
they know right away if something's
going on you know you look here very
similar API for the micro services side
where you have an image of service you
have a CMS service and then you might
have the you know here's some example
DCL as well
where again based on the URL you can see
slash images right there that would send
to a different back in which is the
images server and certain things we may
have to like modify the request URL or
like drain the post body there's all
sorts of like cool stuff you can do
using the power of this system and then
the other really cool thing about this
is these endpoints can be scaled
independently as well so like the images
you can if you have multiple image
providers you're looking at using like
image optimization providers you can
test all of those completely
transparently to your end-users you can
send like a third of your traffic to
each one see which one's faster using
our login logging you can see which one
provides a better occasion percentage
ride because you could set it a cookie
or a header that says which image
service you chose and then your
analytics system could show that to you
and say Oh provider a I got way better
conversion using that so we a lot of our
customers use us for some really cool a
be testing solutions as well or like
green blue deployments last use case I
want to talk about a bit it's just kind
of multi cloud so you've moved out of
the datacenter you're using micro
services you know you you're pretty
proud of yourself of the work that
you've done now you're finding that your
using just one cloud provider out there
is a few like there's a few challenges
with that I know a ton of customers that
are you know cloud native with a single
provider and they're very happy but then
I hear quite a bit from CFOs that they
don't like being so dependent on a
single provider both from availability
perspective or a monetary perspective
right like one of the beauty beauties of
the cloud is you know cost savings right
and cost optimization so with multi
cloud you may be sitting on you know you
know here's a graph or a good diagram
talks about you may be a big Amazon Web
Services customer and you say you know
what I've heard some amazing things
about Google fir they've got amazing
analytics tools they've got really great
technology I mean that's why we're huge
Google fans is both it on the data side
and just the technology side you want to
start taking advantage of moving and
taking advantage of Google right maybe
if you want to do failover between
Amazon and Google and maybe that you're
like you know what quest aren't moving
to Google fully as my primary but I want
to do it in slow order and maybe I keep
AWS as a backup we have quite a few
customers like Shazam and tabouleh who
have done very similar things where they
just want they want flexibility and
options and so with us because of our
load balancer again completely
transparent to the end-user
you can use multiple cloud providers and
even take advantage of the strengths of
each one so data analytics Google's so
good at that you might send some of your
analytics components of your app through
Google but maybe you've got this legacy
after you've built on Amazon that takes
advantage a lot of their tech use in the
traffic for some of that - - the Amazon
that conds completely behind dub-dub-dub
example.com like a lot of our customers
they use their dub dub dub record as
kind of this single ingress point for
all traffic so that they can not just
serve traffic and load balanced traffic
to different backends but maybe they've
acquired technology overtime that they
need to integrate again that dub dub dub
record becomes that universe
we'll source and it also becomes a great
audit point so they can tell where all
their out what all of their applications
and api's are by logging every hit to
dub dub dub and not allowing any traffic
to anything but dub dub dub it becomes a
pretty amazing kind of like audit system
and then like multi-cloud geographic
load-balanced it's really cool to be
able to take advantage of sending
customers to this locations closest to
them right you may have many google
locations where you're running
applications and instead of just
randomly sending traffic to different
locations you want to send if they use
inducers coming from new york you want
to send them to the new york google
location if they're coming from virginia
you want to send the Virginia Google
location if they're coming from
California you want to send into the
California location so we we geo stamp
as well as the have IP and ASN or
autonomous system information about
every single request that we expose to
the user so they can send the traffic to
the closest end user location and then
we help check all the different
locations so in case one data center
taking is taken up for maintenance or
whatever it is we can reroute traffic
instantly to a different location so
here's that here's an example here will
based on a certain path we can create
these health checks that are constantly
checking a particular location or a
particular IP and it's all done again by
our API except and then here's some
logic on the load balancer side that
talks about like it looks at the server
region and it's just the backend and it
makes different decisions based on those
properties to send you to the proper
location so that's it hopefully it was
helpful you know there's a ton we expose
all of our documentation online if you
go to talks not fast icon we've got an
amazing developer portal at developer
about fascinator comm you can take a
look at happy to talk as well if you
ever have any questions I mean it's just
Sean at fastly comm but really
appreciate you taking the time today